hey guys I'm back with Kelly and you
know so we're in the the online news
world or the commentator world or the
what world is this that we're in the
what world the well we're talking with
people that talk about so talk about
style we talk about stuff and one of the
things that I find constantly when I'm
when I'm on Twitter all the time and I'm
talking about this stuff and doing prep
for the show and all that is that
there's an endless amount of bad news
and I don't know if there's more bad
news now than before most studies show
that there actually is there isn't we
think that there's more of I just know
about it more we know about core we see
pictures immediately yes you know who's
the one that actually said comedy is
tragedy plus time yes who actually said
that I don't know who said that kill
Burnett was I think maybe it was Carl
Burnett I think it might have it but now
it's like I see this all the time where
I'm trying I'm almost making fun of
things as they happen because the time
part has been so warm and it's our way
of copious is the whole Gilbert Godfrey
thing I mean this is why he jokes about
what he does is because it's he's trying
to help us cope with it all and he does
it in a way that really pisses people
off because it's two minutes later and
he's lost jobs because of it was like I
go what you can google what happened
there but what I wanted to talk about
with this was there's so much it seems
like there's so much that we're seeing
constantly now between just last week we
had the Australian terrorist attack
today as we're taping this there's this
awful attack in Pakistan there's like
140 dead kids kids in a school you know
we see the Isis beheading zwi see stuff
all over the world and how do you how
much do you let in and how do you stop
it all from getting in yeah cuz I don't
know I tried to do the best I can and I
need to know about it at some level and
then there's some that I'm just like I
can't sometimes there's a story I'm just
like I have to let this one go yeah it
is it's a real balance between wanting
to be a human and knowing what's going
on in the world and being compassionate
and yet also knowing that there's some
sort of overwhelm that can happen if you
let too much of it in too often and I
kind of do it both ways I mean I'm
either really engaged and right on top
of it and watching the Twitter feeds go
down with some of this stuff when I'm in
that mood but in general I try to be
more
detached from it all and my heart goes
out to the individual humans that are
involved in this stuff but like you said
it's always been happening these bad
events I mean maybe there's more I don't
I think that either is it right there
isn't yeah but we do feel like there is
and so therefore I do have to protect
myself I mean if I you know a lot of the
work I do and a lot of writing i do is
personal and deep inside of me and I
have to kind of go in and in order to do
that I have to shut the world out a
little bit and a part of me feels guilty
about that for sure but do you ever feel
like there's something cathartic about
sharing that experience with people
cause like for example during the Boston
bombing I remember very vividly like
watching everyone tweet about and there
were people in Boston that were showing
videos and whatever and I remember
tweeting about and going back and forth
with people and it was like I really
felt like we were all sharing at
something and that was good and then
there's always a point with all of it
that starts feeling gross you know any
may like it does likely feel like this
feeling of like we're talking about it
we're all kind of working through it
together and then there's always a
moment where it's like we don't even let
it sit in what happens ya know well then
the media does it to the 24 hour news
cycle they we're not going to speculate
we speculate you know right it's like
never there's no actual news or
information it becomes kind of an
emotional masturbation yeah it's really
what I feel like it is yeah and I do not
think that is healthy at all but i think
the shared experience is important i
think that creates community that's how
community is built but this other part
we're just kind of going on and on and
on you know you wouldn't want someone in
their personal life going on and on
about a trauma or something like it the
replay of it is can be really reach Rama
tising actually so I don't know it's
yeah it's a real balance I mean I you
know a part of me likes to be detached I
do not read the paper every day my
husband reads that front section every
day and I'll like where's the arts
section I go right to the creative
section yeah because it's like Oh bad
news oh look more bad news Oh more bad
news I'd you know what's so funny too is
we all talk about this that it's always
bad news that's promoted and people say
well why don't they put
good news why is there a station a local
station if you watch the local news it's
always the worst because the local it
pointed maids yeah exactly but people
say well why isn't there more good news
and why don't people do that and the
fact of the matter is and I know this
from from being on YouTube people click
on the bad [ __ ] yeah we do we'll do some
of the I think we try to balance it out
and I don't want people to be too
depressed so we do the silly stuff but
the bad stuff unfortunately where is the
clicks think we're hardwired because i
think it's about safety and security
ultimately so it's like oh can that be
dangerous to me should i worry about
that that's like kind of a hardwired
thing whether and even if it's 10,000
miles away so yeah it's it's a it's part
of a practice though I find I'm a
happier human being which I know sounds
really shallow in some ways when is good
ones but when I don't connect to it all
yeah and it doesn't mean I don't have
empathy and compassion and I'm not
worried about the world but I can't do
anything about Pakistan I mean
unfortunately my tax dollars went to
making the world a much more dangerous
place but that's a whole other time you
know I'm kind of you know in this
already but I do try to you know what I
try to be kind to the people around me
too like that's I dad I know I can
control yeah so well said well this is
one where I truly truly truly want to
know what you guys think because I
because people tweeted me about this all
the time they say oh they're feeling
depressed and how do i blah blah blah so
let us know right down below and and we
will read them and we'll respond and all
that good stuff